>> Dagen: CAN SPIRIT THE
THEORISTS ACCUSING THE
GOVERNMENT OF A MAJOR COVER OF
AN AREA 51.
MORE THAN A MILLION PEOPLE SAY
THEY ARE READY TO'S STORM THE
SITE TO FIND OUT WHAT'S REALLY
GOING ON.
THE VIRAL FACEBOOK EVENT CLAIMS
THAT IF ENOUGH PEOPLE SHOW UP,
THE MILITARY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
STOP THEM FROM GETTING INSIDE.
IT IS SCHEDULED FOR SEPTEMBER.
JESSE ASKED IN THE COMMERCIAL
BREAK THE EXACT DAY SO SEPTEMBER
BREAK THE EXACT DAY SO SEPTEMBE2
BREAK THE EXACT DAY SO SEPTEMBE,
BREAK THE EXACT DAY SO SEPTEMBEJ
BREAK THE EXACT DAY SO SEPTEMBES
BREAK THE EXACT DAY SO SEPTEMBEE
BREAK THE EXACT DAY SO SEPTEMBE.
FROM 3:00 A.M. TO 6:00 A.M.
PACIFIC TIME, THE AIRPORTS ARE
TELLING PEOPLE TO STAY AWAY
SAYING THAT WILL DEFEND THE BASE
IF NECESSARY.
YOU ARE A JOINER.
>> Jesse: I WILL TELL YOU WHY
I WANT TO KNOW THE DATES.
I CONSIDER MYSELF A KOOK
ANTHROPOLOGIST.
I HAVE STUDIED DRUGGIES IN THE
WILD, AND THEIR NATURAL HABITAT,
COMMUNIST, ANARCHIST, PRETTY
MUCH EVERYBODY.
>> Capri: YOU ARE A CULTURAL
ANTHROPOLOGIST.
>> Jesse: I AM.
"WATTERS' WORLD" CAMERAS WILL BE
THERE TO CAPTURE ALL THE ACTION.
I AM SURPRISED TRUMP HAS NOT
SLIPPED UP ABOUT AREA 51 YET.
THE MAN CANNOT KEEP A SECRET.
I DON'T THINK THEY PROBABLY TOLD
HIM ABOUT AREA 51 BECAUSE HE
WILL LET IT GO AT A RALLY OR
SOMETHING.
BUT IF HE'S KEPT THE SECRET, I'M
VERY PROUD.
>> Greg: THESE LITTLE GREEN
GUYS.
SKINNY NECK, SKINNY NECK.
[LAUGHTER]
GREAT PEOPLE, GREAT PEOPLE.
YOU CAN EAT THEM.
THEY TASTE DELICIOUS.
THEY ARE SO SMART.
>> Capri: GO BACK TO YOUR OWN
PLANETS.
>> Greg: BUILDING A WALL.
CAN I MAKE A POINT?
WHEN ARE THESE -- WHAT ARE THESE
PEOPLE GOING TO DO WHEN THEY
SHOW UP WEARING HELMETS AND SHIN
GUARDS BRANDISHING A BROOM.
WHEN THEY COME UP TO A DUDE WITH
A MILITARY I.D.
THE OUTFIT IS NOT GOING TO WORK.
>> Dagen: IS IT A JOKE OR NOT?
>> Dana: APPARENTLY THERE'S A
GUY WHO PUT THE ORIGINAL
FACEBOOK POST UP, LET'S DO THIS
AND HE SAYS HE WAS JOKING.
THE PROBLEM IS NO ONE HAS A
SENSE OF HUMOR ANYMORE SO
EVERYONE THOUGHT IT WAS SERIOUS
AND NOW HE IS SAYING YOU GUYS, I
WAS KIDDING.
IT COULD GET A LIFE OF ITS OWN.
>> Greg: YES!
IT'S A GREAT TIME TO BE ALIVE
THAT YOU CAN TAKE A FEW DAYS OFF
AND GO STORM SOME KIND OF
FOLKLORE, WE HAVE A GREAT
ECONOMY AND PEACE.
THIS IS OUR PROBLEM.
>> Dagen: MEANTIME, THE
KARDASHIANS.
WHAT DO WE WEAR TO AREA 51?
I WANT TO SHOW THIS BECAUSE IT
GENERATED THE POSTING ON
FACEBOOK HAS GENERATED NAMES IN
THIS ONE MADE ME LAUGH OUT LOUD.
WHAT ARE WE REALLY GOING TO FIND
WHEN WE GET TO AREA 51?
DOLLAR GENERAL.
THAT IS RURAL SOUTHERN HUMOR
THAT MADE ME LAUGH.
>> Capri: PLENTY OF
DOLLAR GENERALS ALL OVER OHIO.
I KIND OF WANT TO GO.
I MYSELF WAS CURIOUS BECAUSE I
DO WANT TO SEE THE CLIENTELE
THAT SHOWS UP.
ARE THEY SERIOUS?
WILL YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
ASTROPHYSICISTS?
WILL BRIAN MAY SHOW UP?
I WANT TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE ARE ALIENS HERE.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO GET?
APPARENTLY -- THE OTHER THING TO
BE SORT OF SERIOUS BUT IT'S KIND
OF RIDICULOUS.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT IF HE'S
400,000 PEOPLE SHOW UP, THE
GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
INVEST RESOURCES AND EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE AR-15.
HOW MANY TAX DOLLARS ARE GOING
TO BE SPENT TO PROTECT LITTLE
GREEN MEN?
>> Greg: ONLY THREE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO SHOW UP.
NONE OF THESE GUYS CAN AFFORD A
BUS TICKET.
WATCH THE JOE ROGAN INTERVIEW.
>> Jesse: I DID A
"WATTERS' WORLD" PACKAGE DATA
ALIEN-YOUR VOTE OBJECT HE
COMPETENTLY TOLD THE AUDIENCE,
WHETHER THEY WOULD VOTE FOR
HILLARY OR TRUMP.
NINE OUT OF 10 ARE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
>> Dagen: YOU KNOW WHY?
IS GOING TO SPILL THE SECRETS.
>> Jesse: FISA APPLICATIONS.
LET'S SEE AREA 51 DOCUMENTS.
>> Dagen: WE FOUND OUT IN 2017
THE PENTAGON FINALLY CONFIRMED
THE EXISTENCE OF THE $22 MILLION
PROGRAM TO ANALYZE BASICALLY
WICKING INTO UFOs.
>> Dana: WHAT WASTE OF MONEY.
>> Greg: THE ALIENS ARE LIKE
OUR VERSION OF LIKE SALAMANDERS
OR WHATEVER.
THEY CAN'T DO ANYTHING.
WE ARE THE ONLY PEOPLE HERE.
IT'S PRETTY COOL.
IT'S OUR PLACE.
>> Dagen: SOMEBODY ELSE'S?
>> Capri: NO COMMENTS
"WATTERS' WORLD."
>> Greg: WE ARE JUST LIVING IN
IT.
>> Jesse: ME EXCEPT ALIENS AND